[Music]
[Applause]
bringing Chris Sims pro football talk
live co-host the show that precedes
hours on peacock and of course he's an
analyst for football night America let
me start with the poll question the
quarterback who was drafted this weekend
who is in the best position to succeed
is who oh the best position to succeed
there that that's a good question I
haven't really thought about it through
you know that lens or or frame there you
know
um who would come to mind for right away
well I think what I what came to mind
right away a little bit was just the
perfect marriage and I kind of know what
it's going to look like and how it's
going to look like with Anthony
Richardson and Shane steichen right okay
I think that's where I look at it you
know I wondered what direction the Colts
would go in the draft Shane steichen you
know he was with Justin Herbert in his
rookie year and they were was throwing
bombs all down the field so I thought oh
maybe they'll go a will Levis or that or
what direction is this offense going to
go now we know what direction it's going
to go and they get Anthony Richardson
who's extremely talented he's raw and he
has to play and that's where I think the
situation is really good too so not only
is the scheme perfect for him but
Anthony Richardson like Trey Lance a few
years ago Dan we had those conversations
he had you can't go another year of oh
let him sit on the bench and learn his
number one issue is he hasn't played and
I think that's why Colts are a great
situation for him too why did we think
and I think you had him in your mock
draft that will Levis could end up with
the Colts
well I think that one knowing Chris
Ballard through time and talking to him
a few times and no like he's he's into
Big Time traits Elite traits right
things about guys that go oh whoa that's
special nobody can do that and now we
can build around that and hey coaches
you make them better in some of those
other departments so I had them kind of
pinned as one of those type of guys and
you know those are the two guys that
kind of had the elite trades we know
Richardson Levis probably had the two
strongest arms in the draft they
definitely did uh so that's kind of
where I pinned it and then I worried
about you know all the S2 talk with with
CJ Stroud you know CJ Stroud was my
favorite quarterback but the one thing I
know about the S2 and people around the
NFL and all my friends and connections
there yeah it doesn't uh predict success
but to this point it's predicted failure
or not a hundred percent for pretty
close and I think that's what scared
people too so I wasn't sure if they
would feel comfortable with Stratus 4
but then Levis starts to fall and then I
wonder if this is where mock drafts can
do a disservice sure because we look at
it and and we go oh my God he's dropping
when sometimes the professionals get in
there and start assessing these guys
before the you know the writers do this
and give you a mom we got a mock draft
already for next year yeah right and now
you're already up there and then you
start to fall well it's the player that
we're blaming not the person in the mock
draft who puts them up too high and will
Levis was it just felt like he was too
high yeah well I think everyone bought
into the hype there was a little hype
from last year that carried over into
this year he looks exactly the way you
want the franchise quarterback to look
right he's smart and handsome and you
know looks good on the podium and then
of course he's got a rocket right arm so
all those things fit the bill of oh he's
got to be a top 10 pick he was a
quarterback in the SEC all of that but
like my I mean Dan that's it drives me
crazy unqualified people making qualif
qualifying statements all the time goes
on in this business and yeah like I even
think like the Notre Dame tight end
Michael Mayer phenomenal player right I
mean you were led to believe that he was
a top 10 pick before the draft process
baby Gronk and Notre Dame and everything
there and it's like it's not fair to him
that the expectations are are put up so
high and and I think you're right Dan I
mean I know I had friends and people I
talked to that saw Levis the same way I
did I like some of the things about his
physical tools but it's just
inconsistent and it's all over the place
in a lot of different areas to where
yeah I couldn't have picked them in the
top six seven eight picks that wouldn't
have been for me and I think there was a
lot of teams that felt like that and
that's kind of why he kind of kept
falling down the round we had Matt
Miller from ESPN one of their draft
analysts and I said you know what
happens next year you know if you look
look at these quarterbacks who weren't
eligible Caleb Williams Drake May uh
Michael penick's that's you know these
are really talented quarterbacks and
would probably have been taken ahead of
all of these quarterbacks this year I I
I I I I think so I mean I listen I
really like CJ Stroud I think he is damn
good and he's made for the NFL and I
think he's in not he's in a good spot as
far as the offensive fit I don't you
know they need some Talent down there
would you have taken him over these
quarterbacks Caleb Williams yeah Drake
man this is where it's hard it's hard
like I I I'll say this all right before
the process started and before I dove
into film right because I didn't study
them but before that yourself a TV
scouting yeah I was going
pinnix up in Washington Caleb Williams I
was going those are the top two
quarterbacks in football I go Pedic
should come out he's going to be the
first pick draft he's going to be the
first pick of the draft Caleb Williams I
knew he couldn't come out but I was like
oh he's number one pick next year I mean
he's the closest thing I've seen to
Mahomes and that kind of play you know
since Mahomes in college so yeah I think
there's a very real possibility that if
those two were out this year that those
two would be uh yeah at the top of the
list there okay I don't doubt that at
all but Miller said this he said I see
Arizona on the clock at one next year
they take Caleb Williams and move on
from Kyler Murray whoa whoa okay I mean
that's that's a bold move right there uh
I I don't you know that that is like
goes into a lot of things one you know
with his contract situation and can they
get out of it after next year I'm not
sure they can right you know Kyla Murray
as we know there's some negatives about
him but man I you'd have to be sold that
this guy is just the absolute next thing
because you know Kyler still has some
really special things about his his game
and he's got some Elite traits that we
were just talking about with Chris
Ballard there where you go he can do
some things that nobody else can do so I
I would always be a little hesitant
about throwing that overboard he's Chris
Sims pro football talk live co-host who
had the best weekend what team I mean it
pains me to say it as a Giants fan but I
mean you know who had the best weekend
the freaking Eagles I want to throw a
bunch of four letter words at those
mother effers out there okay I mean damn
they got the 90s Eagles defense and the
92 Cowboy offense that's what they're
rolling into the 2023 season with well I
mean holy crap Bola I I was on Twitter
on on Friday night going Mercy I mean I
give up this is unfair it's the greatest
team building I've ever seen in my life
but you had to get some of the to get
the best player in the draft at nine you
know to get maybe just pure natural pass
rushing Talent the second best one in
the draft in my opinion that 30 and then
everything else you think Corner was the
best player in the draft I do I think
Jalen Carter was the best player in the
draft yeah you know I think if he does
regardless of the position because like
Bijon Robinson to me you is a star you
know he's up there definitely in that
discussion too to what you're saying I
mean he's right there uh but yeah Jalen
Carter was the best interior D lineman
I've ever evaluated coming out in the
draft like it he's you know Jerome Brown
Warren sap-ish right it's that kind of
guy and uh that's where I think he's
really special
but there's concerns yes there is all
right there's some off the field
concerns I know that right and that's
why Philly's perfect because Jordan
Davis's buddies there Nicole B Dean they
drafted him last year he's been the
quarterback of that Georgia defense he's
there he's got of course two teammates
going in there with him this year to
help support him yeah he's got a guy
like Fletcher Cox who's a Hall of Fame D
tackle to show him the way so if there
was one spot to land this was the
absolute greatest spot for him to land
and flourish as a person and a
professional as I'm watching the draft I
don't do social media but I'm watching
going the Jets just got robbed they
wanted an offensive lineman and you know
they got caught
um it felt like the Cowboys got the call
yeah the tight end right yeah right
because Dallas can Jerry Jones can say
whatever he wants Chris but if you watch
that war room those guys definitely did
not know if they should be celebrating
it's almost like uh is this a good thing
and then they almost had to be reminded
we're on camera yeah
no doubt about it yeah no doubt and
Dalton Kincaid I think Dan is was then
that's what the interesting thing about
the draft Yeah Jalen Carter he had Tyree
Wilson Jalen Carter and Tyree Wilson I
think were the top two players in a lot
of people's board but Tyree Wilson had
the foot injury Nolan Smith I think was
our top 10 player for everybody but he
had the pectoral injury Jackson Smith
and jigba Dalton Kincaid I think all
these guys were top 15 players on
everybody's board but they had little
medical issues or issues that kind of
made them fall and Kincaid was he's
phenomenal but you're right I mean it
was one of the few needs that football
team needed there in Dallas and
everybody read the the room the right
way and thinking they might go there the
Jets hey it stinks they lose their
tackle that's the price you got to pay
to get Aaron Rodgers a quarterback and I
don't think they needed another player
on defense well you know so there I
think they're one that you got to think
of where Robert Sala came from right Dan
yeah he came from the Seattle Seahawks
and the 49ers he went to Super Bowls
with those teams because they had
defensive lineman falling off trees
right yeah but you have to protect Aaron
Rodgers well I think there if I had to
just give their side of the story I
would go like this I think they think
and and I know a little of this because
my dad and brother work out with Makai
becton and Jersey he's in phenomenal
shape so I think they're they're feeling
good about that they have Max Mitchell
who played for them last year who they
really like and then I think they're
hopeful that Dwayne Brown you know can
stay healthy and and figure out the year
that way so yeah it's a little bit of a
gamble but if they are healthy up front
the jetso line is better than people are
getting a credit for and now they have
waves of Defense alignment coming at you
too so they're still in a very good spot
and one of the better rosters in
football how would you like to be Marvin
Harrison right now
that you would have been
you know a top five pick I'm guessing
yeah and right and now you have to go
back to college now yeah no nil is going
to give you maybe a million dollars but
you have nothing to prove
you got a new quarterback and you're a
Marked Man but you have to go back to
Ohio State this is where like you know I
wish the NFL you know would use a little
common sense in these type of situations
every now you know I mean like Yogi
Berra says you know common sense ain't
that common and it definitely is not
with some of these conversations here
where hey the guy we just talked about
Caleb Williams he's another one why
can't the NFL get together as a group
and go you know what oh hey we got two
or three guys this year that we think
okay can come out early instead of
risking it and going back to Ohio State
or whatever like you're talking about
and doing that where yeah he could have
came out started making money started
his NFL career what if you had one of
the number one how about a consensus
Chris if you got an unbiased panel that
was assessing Marvin Harrison and Caleb
Williams and said we're all in agreement
that their top five picks right and if
they want to come out
now you know we've been wrong you go to
Christian Hackenberg and everybody
thought he was a number one pick you
know Leonard fournette could have come
out Adrian Peterson could have come out
Marshall
exactly there's certain players where
you go it's not fair that that guy's got
to go back you know Herschel Walker it's
not fair that they're going back to
college no I I like your idea there I do
whether they could like set up some sort
of NFL Legends club ex-players like you
know like a Derrick Brooks and a Warren
Snap Warren Sap and you know maybe a
retired GM and some other front office
people where yeah they could come
together and go hey let's you know let's
evaluate this for what it is and like
you said go okay these guys are ready
let's let's let them come out and
everybody else has to adhere to the
rules whenever we watch the draft it
feels like every team got the guy they
wanted and everybody's going to work out
and it it's like less than 50 percent
that they work out the team that had the
worst draft pick in your opinion in oh
wow
that's a good one there and I don't know
if I'm gonna be able to come up with
that right off the top of my bat let me
I mean right off the top of my head here
let me just look at my computer here
okay did the Lions they took okay and
they took Campbell okay those are two
positions that they took them too early
in my opinion right all right so I'm
with you there I don't love Jordan
Addison by the Vikings in the 20s that'd
be one that I'd go that's way too early
for me okay Jordan Addison's a good
route Runner but I mean you know plays
after the catch and things like that
that's one that confuses me I hear what
I'm not a feeling you were going the
lions were out there I was literally
looking at them on my sheet of paper
here
okay this is where I'll defend the Lions
just a little bit right where agreed
with you Jamir Gibbs they probably could
have got him 10 15 picks later Jack
Cohen probably another 10 15 picks 20
picks maybe even later right but I do
think they had those guys earmarked as
far as wait those are guys we need at
the position and we like them the best
and we felt that they fit our culture
and if they got the guys they wanted and
so be it that it might be 15 or 20 picks
before they should I'm not gonna be mad
at them to ultimately addressing the
need they needed on their football team
with the exact guys they wanted just
because they over drafted you know like
I said 10 or 15 spots so overall yeah
that's the negative about the Lions
draft but damn they needed a big time
tailback they needed a middle linebacker
badly they needed another tight end in
Sam laporta we know they need help in
the secondary right with Devin
Witherspoon not be in there they get
Brian Branch the quarterback so I really
think they did a lot of great things for
their team but yeah to be nitpicky they
over drafted those first two by a little
bit yes what was it like for you when
you were drafted oh
gosh what I mean there was a horrible
great experience all together in one I
the night before I started to get a
feeling that I might drop I went into
the process thinking the Raiders might
take me at the end of the first round
the Ravens were involved in it right
they decided to go with Kyle bowler if
you remember correctly the Raiders had
the last two picks of the first round Al
Davis had basically led me to believe
that they were going to take me with one
of those last two picks so I thought I
was going in the first round right you
know then the night before the draft my
agent was like hey I don't have a spot
for you and anything like that and I
ended up being the last pick of the
third round so you know I spent most of
the first round waiting to get picked
the second round there effing the NFL
and then I got the Raiders passed on you
five times
I know they obviously they have
not like me that's for sure why are you
laughing so hard I'm laughing with you
I'm laughing with you I didn't get
drafted I didn't get drafted no I know
you're just busy making millions
everything else you're doing all right
I'm doing okay uh yes good to talk to
you thanks again
always anytime man tell all the guys I
said hi be good uh guys Chris Sim says
hi hi Chris hi Chris
yeah I like how it's like yeah Al Davis
led me to believe we're gonna take me at
the end of the first round yeah they
passed on you there and then uh the
second round and in the third round too